I remember this was the case with my
childhood like I talked about being very
abusive but I've talked about how like
there was a good amount of meaning there
so that I didn't process it as abusive
at the time and I remember after I got
out of that house in that culture people
would tell me oh your childhood was
really abusive and I was really confused
by that because it's a total
re-contextualization of that narrative
it's like the things that I went through
were not you know good and virtuous and
had meaning but rather those were like
the result of you know parents who
didn't like love you enough or something
uh and it even though the the concrete
things that happened to me did not
change like no facts shifted the fact
that like the the interpretation of the
fact shifted caused me quite a bit of
distress for a long time I was like oh
my God I'm you know I'm a traumatized
like abused person like I went through
an abusive childhood and it was really
hard for me made it worse like it's
crazy the power that terms have
I think we didn't talk about this but
how did you how did you begin to
overcome
uh the the trauma of your childhood you
mentioned LSD so drugs are part of it
like what was the just the mental
journey of that I was doing LSD quite a
lot when I was 21. what's it like by the
way I've never done LLCs what what's it
very difficult to describe because it's
like like it changes sort of aspects
about your environment that are
invisible to you because they're so
stable
is it like if you can compare it to like
psilocybin is it very different oh yeah
uh it's like similar I forgot that you
did shrooms yeah okay that you probably
know you know like the kind of shift
that you have from cyber editions is
roughly similar it's like more clear I
think shrooms is more like embodied but
it LSD is much more intellectual for me
it strikes different people differently
I prefer shrooms a lot I'm sorry LSD
real estate a lot why is it not
popularly take like the there seems to
be a negative connotation to LSD because
like it seems to potentially have like a
destructive effect like maybe dosage is
more difficult to get right or something
like that does this exactly
a long time ago did a survey on streams
versus LSD so I asked people and people
had slightly stronger experiences on LCD
overall I remember but rated the
experience is about is equally good
um but I think people like streams
because it feels more natural
quote-unquote but I think if you like
fed somebody a shroom and like actually
had the LSD molecule in it they would
have a they would think it felt very
natural but that's besides the point I I
like I think people get kind of
incoherent on LSD in a way that feels
really alienating like I consider LCD my
LCD use very heavy to be one of the best
decisions I ever made in my life but I
definitely was incoherent for a lot of
it like talking about like we're all one
Consciousness everything is love man you
know and people are like is that
incoherent so I think it's not
incoherent but like if you go around
saying everything is love people are
like this guy's kind of blasted out of
his mind this podcast
is basically your lsdriver for a bunch
of episodes yeah I get this for sure oh
well well it's not just about love but
it's uh
it's about like talking in that way
about reality about the world yeah sure
it's like overfitting there's the
narratives that you make out the world
become really Vivid and so you pattern
match just really aggressively like
everything is connected and you come up
with these explanations for things and I
think I was very fortunate so I like
this theory about psychedelics where you
either like belief construct or you
don't so you take psychedelics and it
sort of like Burns away a lot of your
belief structure
um and sometimes you this happens and
then you're like I need to like invent
something to fill in the gaps so you're
like okay I I think that maybe uh time
is an illusion so I must now believe
that like we're actually in a Time Loop
or like time travel is possible so you
experience time differently and then you
come up with a different belief about
time uh whereas other people uh don't do
this belief construction at all like you
experience time differently and you sort
of let yourself not have a belief you're
not like okay and you're not developing
any beliefs about time in its absence
you're just simply experiencing the
absence of the concept of time right uh
and so I I don't have a lot of data to
back this up you know my anecdotal
experience because I've trips at a lot
of people people either tend to believe
construct or they don't and people who
do not believe construct seem to get
more out of their LSD trips so if you
can let a belief go without building
anything in its absence it's much more
beneficial for you and I think I just
for some reason happen to have some
brain that's constructed where I don't
get a belief construction at all so oh
that's really interesting that belief
construction is negative
what
is it necessarily a negative can you
elaborate on that a little bit I mean
belief Construction in a way that's like
uh
not like playing with frames but rather
committing to a different frame
so I'm not sure I like I like being able
to play with ideas and be like let's
look at it this way or that way that's
awesome but if you're like okay you know
what I took LLC and now I absolutely
believe the cops are outside and you're
like dude no you're just like you you
can't shift out of that right like your
brain like needs to fill in the Gap
you're not allowed to have a gap so
you're not allowed to be flexible and
again I don't think this is like a
personal failing if any I think this is
like literally probably a genetic or
like physical thing that's causing this
but do you think there's possible
beliefs that are like enlightening that
you can stick to like find a frame
that like
I guess if you don't believe
constructing your escaping your previous
beliefs aren't you doing like just some
you're picking up a bigger frame
yeah in some way you're taking your
beliefs as object as opposed to being
subject to them ah got it got it got it
got it and some of that I guess is
genetic and there's these categories of
people there's two categories that
experience LSD in different ways yeah
and you're one of those that are able to
just let go yeah I just think I had a
good reaction and I think a lot of maybe
the negative stereotype of LSD comes
from people who are belief constructing
or carry the belief constructing off of
the LSD trip so you take LSD and you're
like ah I'm leaving these insane things
and people from the outside see that and
they're like oh my God this person took
outstand became stupid it's very scary
um what's frame control because that's
been at the core of your trauma at the
core of your upbringing what's frame
control and also no sorry frame control
in general because that's part of human
interaction uh yeah Fame control is like
a way of manipulating somebody else that
is none uh obvious so there's a negative
competition to that usually uh yeah I
mean I think maybe I chose the term kind
of poorly because I think to some degree
people are always a little bit
manipulating each other but I think it's
generally obvious like for example if I
disagree with you I want you to believe
what I believe yeah but this is like an
obvious thing that is like visible
between it's like an object on the table
it's like here's the box where I want
you to believe what the disagreement box
yes like right like we're under a shared
context where we understand that like
we're trying to move each other yeah
this is Chill to me I think this is cool
yeah we just all the time and it's
important but frame control is the kind
of thing where you are trying carefully
to obscure the existence of that box
yeah you're like oh um the thing that
I'm doing I'm like using tactics to try
to influence what your reality is
without us being both aware that this is
what I'm doing yeah I've been assuming
you're doing that the whole time
no oh my God
I have to like figure out how to read
your facial expressions I'm still
learning there's none there's none you
don't have any I'm like uh I'm not even
like a Chad gbt I'm like gbt one with my
facial expressions like it's kind of off
like this doesn't seem to match emotions
but it's kind of intelligent seemingly
but definitely not conscious anyway so
like uh negative connotation
manipulating right not being honest
about the actual intentions of the uh
yeah of how you'd like to to control the
conversation I think there might be a
naive version of interpreting this where
you're just like oh I'm trying to like
subtly get you to you know believe like
oh do you really think that's bad though
but this is not quite what I mean I mean
it's like a couple of concrete things
that are signs of frame control
um like one of them is pushing the
painful update button um which is this
thing where it's like uh Hey if you uh
learn this it's going to be really
painful the truth is painful and if
you're realizing this thing about
yourself it's gonna hurt and this is a
sign that you're heading in the right
direction so if you frame all pain as a
sign of virtue and this means that pain
that's resulting as as damage is
something you're going to ignore
so it's like this it's a common like
Cults right this is for your own good oh
uh you know you've faced the brave truth
about yourself that you're like not
quite as wise as I am
um when really your brain might be
trying to tell you protective things or
like another one is like finger trap
beliefs
um where you the belief is constructed
in such a way that doubting it lends
proof to the belief it's a very common
example is like Satan like the
Christians are like uh you know Satan is
going to try to make you doubt him the
existence of he's going to so doubt like
maybe he's not actually real and so if
you believe in Satan and then you're
like okay now I'm having doubts like
maybe he isn't real this is like oh this
is exactly what I was taught to expect
like I am doubting this belief because I
was told because like this is what Satan
does and it's taken as evidence for it
so like the attempt to move away from
the belief like re like rebounds on you
and like causes you to be more embedded
inside of the belief yeah so it's like
techniques like this like very subtle
things where like being inside of this
system sort of just self-reinforces the
system is what I consider to be frame
control
and have you met people that are really
good at this kind of frame control
yeah yeah definitely so like you you're
saying that your father was like that
yeah to be fair I'm not sure he was good
at it because I was a kid right I think
he's probably not very good at it
actually but when you're a child being
raised in a house where he works from
home and you're homeschooled uh it's
just kind of what's going to happen and
to be fair I do think that like strong
frame control is quite rare I don't
think most people are kind of doing
something like this but not nearly to
the degree that makes gives me the ick
yeah uh I've met maybe like five or six
people I think who I really don't like
because of those very subtle things that
they're doing well I think also I'm
starting to kind of understand that
there is people who are
narcissists and sociopaths and
Psychopaths out there
and um
I'm not even sure if people like that
because I think they get good at frame
control
but I don't know if they're aware
they're doing it oh yeah which makes me
also nervous about myself like am I
doing frame control
yeah that's one of the big things it's
like like typically people you can't
think about incentive like you can't
think about oh is this person trying to
do it or not yeah it's like not the
quite not the way you have to look at
what are the effects programmatically
looking at the effects and then you also
have to do that with yourself when you
have the interactions it's like very
much like are you like how much space
are you making for the other person's
reality here like sure are you are you
giving power to the other person because
a big aspect of frame controls you're
carefully rerouting the power to
yourself
you're like I am the person who knows
I'm like you're having pain in your
beliefs because you're updating towards
the things that I believe like it's it's
just like a gravity well but if you're
if you're setting up the gravity well of
your interaction such that you're making
sure you're giving the other person
power over the shared reality you
inhabit I think it's a really good sign
that you're not doing problem control
so if you're making room for them yeah
okay unless we're talking about embed
then it then then it's all general
relativity from there and black holes
and stuff frame control bed frame
control bed frame control
um it took me a long time to get a bed
frame just I'm saying I know but you
wear a suit though
uh yeah uh so frame control on the
streets no frame in the sheets I don't
know I don't know what the funny thing
is to say though but there you have it
um so the LSD helped you escape the the
frame
of uh
can you like elaborate what what was the
frame that was
holding you back
from
like the frame constructed by your
childhood experience that was holding
you back as an intellectual as a thinker
as a free being in this world
I was really [__] up like after I left
home and I it absorbed the external
narrative that I had been abused which
technically is true I'm not saying I
wasn't but like I absorbed this
narrative and I just remember having
like this burning coals in my chest at
all times like if I had to call out of
my factory work when Father's Day
happened because I was spending the
whole day sobbing because everybody's
talking about their fathers like I was
really messed up and it was because I
held this important thing this this idea
this Frame that I had been deeply
wronged like there was a correct way of
being and the world had violated that
something should not have happened like
my father should have left me and it was
like this this like like the shearing in
the nature of reality and that was
really agonizing to have and LSD really
messes with frames a lot it takes like
what you think is normal and really
screws with it and I didn't LLC like
several times before but there's one LSD
trip where I remember I went through my
entire childhood in my head because LC
like really makes your memories quite
Vivid like anything you visualize it's
like you're in it and so I just went and
very carefully deliberately went and
remembered every single memory that I
could have that was really painful for
me like the times that I lost friends
and all the things I valued and like
being broken because like my parents
especially my dad would refer to like
breaking me like explicitly we're gonna
break your will as all these times where
I was like they had successfully broken
I will over and over and it was horrible
I was just like sobbing tears streaming
down my face and then I like worked
through my whole child I got to the end
and I'm gonna tear up because every time
I talk about this it's just like the
sensation of like being free from that
for the first time is so incredible like
I remember
being outside of my house and
being able to like
go where I wanted and think what I
wanted and
uh it was just just so Blissful and I
was soaked in this gratitude on this
trip just like vibrating with complete
joy for everything like I was just
looking around like I could touch
anything like I could cry if I wanted to
I wasn't allowed to cry I was going to
be depressed I was trying to I got
depressed as a child and my parents were
like if you keep being depressed we're
gonna like force you to scrub the whole
house like just like the ability to have
a feeling
uh was so thrilling and I was so
grateful for this I was like I would do
anything to give this experience to
someone else or do anything
even if it was like putting them through
what I went through and then like with
that realization I was like oh it was
worth it the thing that I went through
was worth it for this I would do it
again to like be able to have this deep
gratitude for what I have now and then
that shifted the meaning frame because
before the meeting had been like
something had sheared something that
shouldn't have happened but now it's
like the exact right thing had happened
so it's almost a gift yeah I was like ah
I would not give up my childhood I would
do it again
and I believe that to this day for the
moment of discovering that freedom yeah
because like everything now my whole
life is in contrast to that and it's
awesome it's [__] great I'm really
thrilled about it
do you
is the part of you that hates your
father still
kind of like I don't want a relationship
with anymore after that there was some
forgiveness like I had this Burning I
would have nightmares about you know him
killing me or something and after that
it kind of stopped like the the fire in
my chest went away permanently after
that trip it was so fast it was like
before I was [__] up after that trip I
woke up the next day and I was clean wow
it was really severe uh and I definitely
don't want to be around him still like
he still like triggers the fear in my
body yeah but I don't have that hang up
anymore I'm like kind of I'm over it
like I've let go he's his own person
like ultimately he didn't get to decide
who he was in the same way that I didn't
get to decide who I was
so that's almost like a kind of at least
intellectual like forgiveness yeah for
him yeah
and that so that that trip just took you
through your whole
year Alone by the way when you're doing
the trip uh yeah I had roommates but the
trip was mostly alone I had somebody
else was like sitting in the room but
they weren't interacting with me so
you're sitting there experiencing all
this what's the timeline like how long
does it take to go through your whole
childhood I don't remember I mean time's
really messed up when you when you I was
listening to the soundtrack of the
fountain which is excellent yeah I
listened to that a lot when I did LSD I
know it's probably a couple hours
that's amazing I mean it's like
it would be all
it's just like a vivid experience of
your childhood Moment by moment trauma
by trauma
it's good to experience it purely like
it just is what it is it just is grief
like it is loss
and you just are in it without having to
make it be anything
and it's so interesting that you can I
mean work through that so for a lot of
us
for a lot of human beings like childhood
is full of those kind of mini
traumas big or small and like working
through that it feels like what a lot of
life is about is trying to work through
that
and it feels like you have to kind of
relive it I guess that's what therapy is
about in part and be able to vocalize it
yeah I this is why I feel really
confused about the concept of trauma
like people use this word so much like
are you traumatized and I understand why
like this is why I feel confused about
it but part of me is like I wonder if by
using that term we're creating the
trauma in people they were using the
frame where the thing that happened to
you was not supposed to happen yeah yeah
maybe there needs to be a different
frame no I I agree with you thought I
just I've I've made friends with and
talked to this guy named uh Paul Conte
he wrote a book on on trauma he's an
incredible brilliant psychiatrist yeah
he's probably agrees with your kind of
oh that's cool I should read it yeah you
should
um maybe even talk he's a fascinating
human being I'd be um interested in the
um
a psychiatrist's perspective is really
interesting because it's a you did
you've been doing kind of an in-person
survey
because you've done done so many
patients like like he he's like just
talking to him
is fascinating because like if I
describe my experience or somebody
else's experience it I could see his
brain mapping it in interesting ways to
the tens of thousands of of like data
points he has in his head and it's like
of course that's what doctors do but
it's cool as the doctors basically the
doctor of the mind and um to have like
an actual like like qualitative data and
be able to I mean that's where the
poetic stuff comes in ultimately as a
psychiatrist you're exploring the human
mind with a bit of a sort of romantic
element yeah it can't be really
systematic about it but it does seem
like frame or not be able to just talk
through the experiences you had is
really powerful what about it is
appealing is it just like being able to
revisit it with new eyes no I don't know
exactly it just seems to work for people
I don't know if it's appealing it just
seems like
almost acknowledging to yourself that
things happen
um like I've said uh I think I've said
this before my brother who I love very
much I tried to set me on fire a few
times
and I I think I to me it's funny but I
wonder if I didn't talk about it like if
that would be traumatic maybe like
talking and laughing about it
because it was traumatic to me at the
time I see I was like I love you why are
you setting that fire but that's what
kids do when they're like yeah
I was like I was whatever fights this is
what boys do like it's they're crazy uh
it makes total sense it's probably funny
and from his perspective
but yeah I wonder I want to bring that
to the surface of that that helps and
maybe LSD allows you to uh or different
drugs depending on the person allows you
to more vividly bring it to the surface
and then depending on your genetics be
able to find a better frame
that's fascinating human mind is
freaking fascinating